you know what i'm saying so sure yeah
she she started recording music in 2020
right and before that you said you said
when you got out of jail
when did you get out of jail uh i want
to say it was 2019 2019 2018 22 2019
2018 2019 transition around there
so that was just straight juvenile
because you know
yes i was i was i they sent me uh to
duvall county uh you know jacksonville
sure yeah so they sent me to do a county
all the way from palm beach and i did
like two years it was it was pretty
serious we were labeled as medicine
societies because
when you're juveniles they'll give you
slapping a wrist and um you know when
you're a kid and you're running wild you
know you're a little alive until i turn
21 i'm still delinquent so oh so you
said they sent you to jacksonville
because they didn't want you guys to be
in the same spot because you cannot no
you can't i can't be in the same mod the
same dorm right why because you're
related yeah yeah you could i mean they
consider a gang i mean you could jump
you could jump some people yeah
right yeah you can team up yeah so
that's why they sent you to jacksonville
and you know that's not why uh basically
it's like it's like the same thing as an
adult where you sit down a county and
they when you get sentenced they send
you to prison so basically i sat down in
a juvenile detention center waiting
waiting for ed i did that time i didn't
get no time served and then what's it
called because i i literally the day i
got committed because that's what you
get sentences juvenile they consider
committed the day i got committed uh
they passed a law where you cannot get
you can't get released home and wait to
to wait till you uh go up the road so
you had a city you can't get no house
arrest that's not yet so you had to sit
down and wait until you get transferred
to the program that you're supposed to
go to and then that's when i put this on
everything i'm not lying i'm the one
that sat the most out of everybody i did
seven months that time in juvenile
detention
everybody asked me
everyone kept telling me you sat here
the mo the longest in in here and i'm
like why they're like they just keep red
flagging because you keep getting in
fights you keep going to comply but i
don't really believe that i'm like
that's a myth they just don't want me to
well getting in fights when you're in
custody is not really yeah it's not it's
not a good idea but you could get in
fights in there yeah and do it on
now when they send you to a gram it's
called a grant when they send you like a
juvenile prison when in dubai when they
say that you catch time for fighting
i remember being in jail in florida i
was in jail in
orlando orlando
it was it was 10 days that i was
sentenced to for my second dui and i did
all 10 days
and i remember like they they had us in
like a big [ __ ] like gymnasium with
all bunk beds there would have been a
hundred [ __ ] open bay open bay yeah i
didn't know orange county i didn't know
this county's open but it was 1996 had
to have been a hundred bunk beds 1999
and if you [ __ ] around yeah if you
[ __ ] around if you got any trouble
this guy's been around for a while yeah
i'm old
if you got any trouble they would say
pack your things you had like a little
[ __ ] uh like um not a mat it was like
a bus boy
without being on camera everything was
on camera even in the bathroom yeah even
in the bathroom even in the bathroom and
if you got in trouble then pack your
things meant you're going down into like
the dungeon where presumably everything
is
steve still jerks off on camera yeah
no i saw a camera right in the corner it
was like a little camera it's it's like
hidden and i'm like i'm gonna jerk my
dick off right on camera and then i'm
gonna rap right after yeah i know nicole
and the kavanaugh cell
they didn't have a camera but
confinement
there's people that don't care though
yeah but steven let me ask you a
question as crazy as you are when you
were in jail
how did that feel were you were you
going crazy
um i mean it was only ten days it's only
ten days did you know you get it did you
know he was getting out well i can't get
like i knew that i was gonna get
sentenced
to some time because there was no way of
me saying i didn't drunk i wasn't drunk
driving i mean they got me yeah they got
me good it was my second
drunk driver didn't you say you got me
what do you mean yeah that was my first
dui so he got me the second one i tried
to kind of put up a fight but but it
wasn't gonna work and uh
what it was was i i lived in like
around uh like boca raton i was west
palm beach area
and i had gotten arrested while i was at
a skateboarding convention in orlando
and and yeah i was driving drunk at this
[ __ ] and so i had to go back to
orlando for my arraignment and i just
said hey man like i could barely afford
the [ __ ] greyhound bus to get to
orlando i don't want to go back and then
back and forth and back and forth i
showed up to my arraignment and i asked
for permission to plead guilty right
away and go straight into jail to just
get it all done in one trip in just 10
days 10 days they told you it was 10
days yeah they told us 10 days and and i
want to take nothing over too
sit down i'm not saying i i you know
someone so when you came out how did you
feel well i was stoked as hell because
they uh they let me have
paper and a pencil and i started writing
my [ __ ]
i wrote jailhouse memoirs i wrote my
script were you steve all the time i
dude the first [ __ ] thing i wrote on
my first page was hello
they call me stevo but i'm thinking
about switching back to stephen steve
glover because i've kind of begun a
career now and i don't know if i want a
nickname when i'm famous
that's the first [ __ ] [ __ ] i wrote
and that's your opponent
my real name is stephen glover yeah i
ended up like
you know doing a show and they were i
called myself stevo and the crowd was
chanting steve oh and so so what what
got you big exactly because i used to
watch you as a kid but i used to look at
you like a stunt double like you know
not a stunt double i was just a stunt
[ __ ]
so like so like i'm single so yeah i
would see you get like like uh you know
shot in the ass
yeah i did a bunch of dumbass [ __ ] we
ran a show on mtv and we ended up making
it into movies and stuff and and and
that all began in year 2000 yeah now
it's so uh so it's been 22 years i bet
your ass has a whole bunch of scars from
bb yeah it's getting shot can i ask you
a question i saw a video you're getting
punched by what ufc fighter in the
stomach
oh i didn't get punched by a ufc fighter
in the stomach that think that i'd have
been somebody else is that when he broke
his nose on mike tyson's fist
man you got punched in the stomach at a
hotel room
i don't i don't think that was that was
me that doesn't ring a bell
oh okay yeah but but in any case man
i've been at it for a long time i've
been in jail a bunch of times
and uh you know and i get it
um you said you were you were down in
the juve for two years he was to
both of you i just did a little bit more
time because i i cuz you had the
aggravated with the firearm no i i
didn't oh you had the aggravated that
was when i was an adult though yeah
that's when he was adult i mean that's
[Applause]
yeah i mean somebody tried to chime in
miami you know how it is someone tried
trying to miami south beach and i said
where you at and pull up and i put a gun
it was a six foot tall guy with a i'm
not gonna i'm not glad he he did that
for me because i told him i'm like yo
somebody's trying to fight him i said
okay so i'll pull up and i put the red
beam on you once you know they got
scared and they ran and he ran to the
police and they called the cops red bean
that's just creepy
a six foot tall guy i would have anybody
would you know i'm six feet tall i would
run two no no he was bigger than you
yeah there is nothing [ __ ] about
running from a red beam
on your forehead and he was a gangster
and he went police
yeah i mean hey dude you you know you
know i bonded out the same night my bomb
was high as [ __ ] you know it was three
of them right it was three of them
yeah they ran like a [ __ ] my bomb was
high as [ __ ] and i was sitting in miami
and trk it's like that it was around
this time actually like spring break
though there were tourists i know they
and i had and i and um i'm sitting there
i'm like man you know i got all these
tattoos at the time already i'm like i
look like a celebrity one one staff
tried to call me at six nine i said
don't call me no [ __ ] six nine six
nine and huh what's six nine six nine
six uh yeah she tried to call me six
nine and she and she threw me in
confinement because i caught her [ __ ]
so when she threw me confirmed i'm
freezing cold i'm shirtless with all my
tattoos and i said i i prayed and i said
i am never going back in here and then
one of the staffers says hey man i like
you man come on come on real quick i'm
gonna take you out of confinement [ __ ]
what she's talking about and uh let me
let's let's get you up we're gonna put
you all the way upstairs and stuff like
that put you dressed up i'm like hey
listen i'm just trying to get bonded out
he's like what did you do your but your
bond's pretty high and i'm like did you
did you shoot no i'm like no i did not
anytime your charge starts with the word
aggravated
remember i asked the cop i asked cop so
how many times did you charge me with
aggregate assault
she said one time
and then i go in there and they said
they charged me twice and i said oh okay
there's aggravated assault with a
firearm and then there was like
improperly showing a weapon or something
there's some weird [ __ ] it was pretty
it's pretty serious what does the word
aggravated mean in this aggravated means
like like it's a violence
there's aggravated homicide there's like
it's like sort of like just like you
know you you did you you went all in
yeah everybody outside yeah yeah
yeah but it was it was a south
it was a self-defense thing i mean the
guy was trying to uh fight him and stuff
like that i mean like are you trying to
fight you keep forgetting as a group
there's a group of people people trying
to die
trying to jump him i'm like i'm like i'm
like bro you're not gonna jump him well
i'm glad to be i'm glad you beat the i'm
glad you beat the charge it's so funny
because his charges were way more
serious his lawyer was cheaper and he he
he beat that he beat those charges and
then the other one that i got
[ __ ] the other one i got charged
with was false
had uh you know i wouldn't be surprised
if it had something to do with the the
people
yeah they called the cops at first but
they probably didn't stick around to
come cooperate in court right right no
yes yes you're right they weren't they
you're right about that i told you
they're from a different state you're
right about that right
don't worry i'm like they're not gonna
even testify they're not gonna do it
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and
sky jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
yeah
me
[Applause]